look into the camera please and let
comics know why they should be listening
to this you should be listening to the
hot breath podcast because number one
the host is very informative and ask
good pertinent question because you
could learn some if you shut the [ __ ] up
and watch for a minute which a ad deed
Millenial asses and because I'm on here
and we're trying to keep it 100 and he
had the foresight to come and interview
me and I'm just trying to keep it real
and help you aunt you don't mean no harm
but if you suck like it out the way
please
luenell thanks for being on hot breath
yes man just say and if you suck get out
the way come on go get her awesome great
interview Thank You Lou no I'm really
encouraging to the [ __ ] out of the way
loser
you're [ __ ] loser
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah it's video - yeah we've got a boat
yeah no you're great you're great right
there actually yeah I turn the ISO up on
it but um definitely that's gonna be
next but you know we're we're in the mud
right now hot breath so our interview a
bunch of different comics about the
craft and their journey and I really
want this to be like Inside the Actors
Studio but for comedians
but what's amazing what I've learned is
that people actually going into the
weeds on comedy people actually are
gravitating towards it they want to hear
like oh how'd you develop that joke and
how did you get confidence on stage in
like oh wait you were incarcerated but
then you shot a movie in the jail that
you were in like that kind of crazy stop
we're rolling now we are rolling okay we
are official all right hey so even just
watching you just to dive in here for
you know I get an introduction would you
like to I would like to you to introduce
me okay
all right hot breath averse we are back
with another hopper episode here a comic
of the people we have on the show today
not only she started from the bottom now
she's here now I'm in the middle you're
in the middle in the middle well this is
the comedian we can all learn from just
her hustle her overall perseverance her
approach to comedy also in terms of
focusing on it as a crap can they see me
am i blending into the wall I think can
they can you see them can you see me
everybody I look like little ant
my seats higher than yours too well you
just come on down to my left well that's
what most people do about that zebra
bump Shh
I will go to whatever level you're at
cuz I'm right here in the middle okay
I'm ready so she uses her theatre
background to be an actual performer on
stage and not someone who just tries to
pass by on attitude so you want to learn
from this interview just how you can use
this craft not only from a business
sense but also to hone it and take it
seriously and not just try to come up on
a sweet lick as we say love it so I
introduced to you hot breath verse the
one and only luenell everyone even in
speaking of sitting down the I've
watched through the past two nights
standing ovations every single time
thank you why do you think that is what
do you what are you doing to evoke a
standing ovation from these people well
besides the fact that I have fans that
are I've been riding with me like nipsey
would say for many years but I think
that there is a refresh refreshing
quality to a comedian who is not
buckling under the pressure being a
little italy-- correct
who is calling it what it is who is
saying what everybody is thinking and
Aaron and what we're feeling being a
female comic I don't want to ever
alienate guys I like guys to come see me
too but they need to hear what the women
are saying in a way you know it's like
when your mom tells you something but
you won't listen but your aunt tells you
the same thing your mom did and you'll
listener mm-hmm so they'll listen to me
and I'm just here to help them for every
you know speak for the chick speak for
fat change speak for older chick speak
for mothers big for lovers speak for all
of that and I'm just refreshing as a
[ __ ] and you've been in this
game like thirty years how long cuz we
all as comedians I've been doing comedy
over nine years now and we all want to
have that voice where I want to have
that confidence but how long into the
game did it take you before you were
like oh I actually had the confidence on
stage to just tell it as it is and not
try to like hide behind
cleverness I've always been this way for
the entire thirty years because of my
theater background I never really had
stage fright and when I do comedy it's
like a purging for me like if I don't do
it you know I should leave land back in
jail you know for slapping the [ __ ] out
of somebody or slapping somebody this
okay to speak mine yes say what you want
I don't want to offend anyone and so
it's it's very meditative for me I think
that I'm being the ace of eight children
mm-hmm you know I really didn't have a
voice or anybody to listen to me very
much and this way it's not even a
democracy is a total dictatorship it's
what I say for a [ __ ] hour and I get
to voice my opinion I get to talk to
somebody too so as I told the audience
this is therapeutic for me to do it for
them as it is for them to get it from me
and your timing though it's you're
almost you're just in no hurry up there
you're almost just breathing through
your jokes you're like I'm gonna say
these things on my time you'll wait for
me is there a power in the silence is
that what you have found to be able to
draw the audience to you because what I
found in watching you is you can get
them up but you can be like all right
let me tell you this and then they just
they just go back to zero if you say
listen up they all just settle right
back down so how are you able to almost
like hypnotize them in a sense to where
you you just manipulate the audience on
your every word well I think respect
plays a lot respect in it they respect
you they'll want to hear what you have
to say even though I understand people
are drinking people are celebrating
people are partying people are you know
high-fiving making deals soaking up on
grindr all that [ __ ] during my show all
that's going on you know but when you
have something to say if you can take a
bunch of loud drunk people and then you
can like this and make them all go
that is because they want to hear what
you have to say because you're saying
something
if you're talking nonsense and it's not
hitting and relating into the souls of
people you're gonna lose them but should
I say kids'll somewhere because I'm
talking about real [ __ ] that you know
what I mean I'm talking about [ __ ] that
is colorless talking about kids in
college I'm talking about sex since it's
colorless that's why my audiences you
can have a trump supporter with a
confederate flag t-shirt sitting next to
a Mexican said next to a white
transgender said mixture of Rastafarian
like on a cruise ship and that's what I
want because my comedy is for everybody
that's what I've noticed in doing comedy
is I start I'm here in Atlanta and I
started out in primarily like urban
rooms like where I'm the only white guy
in like the zip code because that's
where I could get booked and I have
noticed that comedy is somewhat
segregated yeah comedy was absolutely
segregated and we like it that way
because people want it no but like if
you have Aziz you know as a headliner
and all the Persians or whatever want to
come see Aziz they don't want to sit
through too white or very instance of
black hacks to get to the headliner they
want to they want to hear what they want
to hear what they can relate to that's
why you would have Persian night or
Latin night okay night no chocolate
Thursday you know Mexican Monday or
whatever like that is segregated so you
can hear [ __ ] that relates to you but if
you're a comedy fan and kind of soaring
a student you listen to all of it mm-hmm
I don't stay in black rooms ever I just
did an all-white room at the Comedy
Store with because I have a specialist
on Showtime right now called funny women
of a certain age and they do a traveling
thing
and I did there our white audience in at
the Comedy Store on you know wasn't
worried about a thing because I'm
talking about his trans racial cuz it's
real okay
so young comics may be a big mistake
they're making is they're just not being
real they're trying too hard they're
trying to find out who they are the joke
stealing they can't even punch it up
good they don't know see I'm also I have
a Bachelor of Arts degree in English
literature so I know how to weave a
story I know what a segue is nobody's
teaching them because they think they
know every goddamn thing so you can't
teach them because I know every [ __ ]
thing so we don't normally [ __ ] with the
young ones cuz they don't want any of
our advice in him I don't want to give
advice when you don't take it if I give
you advice you should probably take it
so I can get paid for giving [ __ ]
advice you know so it's just that they
don't you know they're dead they're not
just studying the craft they don't know
who the old comics are they don't give a
[ __ ] they don't know about technical
standup I know kids that are going out
doing sensor don't even know to move the
microphone to the back you know like
what the [ __ ] is that like where did you
learn this [ __ ] and then you want to be
paid yeah I've heard you say even you're
thinking about starting like almost like
making it a business where you can
mentor comedians and help them alive
that's where all that gristle went
though yeah what are some other major
mistakes you're seeing comedians maker
what's other advice you can share with
comics I don't understand comments
coming to do their set and not staying
to watch the other comic they want to do
three rooms in the night but if you're
not learning anything you're just
spinning your wheels doing three [ __ ]
room wasting time Liat like watch don't
you want to be a headliner one day so
why don't you watch and see what the
headliners doing you know why don't you
see how they work to cry what they do
and watch that same person if you like
them over and over again and study they
don't study anything you can't learn
comedy on Instagram [ __ ]
matter what people tell you baby you
know what you don't like these Instagram
comedians no I think they have a lane
for sure yes some of them are very
talented and I think they can be great
actors but not comics you can call an
Instagram celebrity Instagram
entertainer Instagram sensation but not
an Instagram come because you ain't one
cuz you can't be one
so another thing comics lets you
actually go out and pursue it and love
it exactly do that then you can't cross
over from being a hack into being a
professional that's what some of the
best advice I've ever gotten is just to
live on stage yeah I don't write
anything down
maybe now and then I might write bullet
point but something might happen on the
way here and I'm gonna talk about it
there and that's of my mmm I don't go
work out you know I work it out like
right now you know and another thing not
only a performance but your business
side of comedy is something that you I
think have a lot of good lessons for
comics because you're moving beyond just
stand up you're making a lot of
different moves so what are some
business tips you have for comics well
learn how to do your taxes immediately
I'll be extorting from the banks ah
whatever your claim examine oh and if
you get the opportunity to join sag do
because comedy has no union you will
never have healthcare doing comedy you
will never have dental or I care doing
comedy you will be a broke [ __ ]
with our hospital bill if you just rely
on comedy you must unfortunately cross
over into acting so you can get some
benefit which is [ __ ] because comedy
is one of the only entertainment genres
that doesn't have a union and the comedy
clubs don't want you to have a union
they don't want to pay healthcare for us
give a [ __ ] about us they always have I
remember back in the day hearing about
the stance that they were going to take
it to Comedy Store gives me sure and you
know it's like a Letterman and all I was
like we need to get paid you're like
[ __ ] you not a goddamned
there's people lined up down the street
you want to do it [ __ ] you do you get a
[ __ ] out of here and let the next
[ __ ] come here but if you get
stage time and you can be discovered and
that's a steal don't pay [ __ ] at the
Comedy Store
yeah and there's almost tears it's
almost like in comedy it's either you
don't have it or you've got it there's
no real middle ground in terms of just
like the pay it's still well I don't
know I'm sort of middle ground because I
don't have it
oh you know what I look like I got it I
don't have it how can you have it you
have it I love two blocks from the
marathon store you [ __ ] kidding me
you just bought a snake ring yesterday
though I didn't know you're up there but
you were also able to pay your daughter
through school like you're a financial
aid that's true that's a success as you
don't even know the gifted she's got not
having financial aid dead [ __ ] up that
forever 21 what are what are other like
business mistakes you're seeing comics
make or how cuz even me like I'm nine
years in and I've been focusing really
hard on getting good at comedy which I
it's a lifelong journey I'm by no means
saying I've mastered it in the least but
I can competently stand on stage at
least where I perform ever I mean here I
host a Wednesday here I perform multiple
times a week and I'm now in the comedies
that many spots like you live here and
so there's like spots to hit Atlanta you
can get up multiple times a night that's
like New York yeah I love it
that's why I'm still here I was I was
just in New York this past weekend with
actually a Mary Lindsey oh yeah how do
you like this is the question how does
East Coast comedy rooms different from
southern rooms or West Coast room
what I found is if it's real then you'll
connect with the audience no matter
where it is like I have found they I
don't any joke I have to tailor to a
certain audience I get rid of yeah I
don't do that either yeah Museum yeah
that's been my goal though to perform in
a church that I could say in a nightclub
that I could say in a comedy club okay
yeah used to perform at the Noe Valley
ministry in San Francisco they did
comedy in the church no drinks though
[Laughter]
well we're we're approaching our 15
minutes here so this is like a comedy
mastery show so any other to keep the
microphone as a consolation prize you
can keep this water though that's your
water no that's hot breath water that's
our branded hot breath in it I might
keep that's how the gristle got knocked
out hey friends I'm hot Breslin if you
want to keep up with me you can catch me
on my Instagram at luenell at lue in e
ll or my facebook the official email I'm
sure you know how to spell official I
don't high right now and I don't or you
can also get me on my website at hey
luenell comm h ey l ue in e ll dot-com
and if you'd like to sign up for my late
night mentorship program for young
gentlemen
between the ages of 24 and 47 please hit
me on my Instagram slide into my D and
something the picture from the neck up
thank you
and are you gonna open up that foot
fetish website this year you know I
really is that something can look out
have amazing seat although I did have an
accident in New York and I cut my
[ __ ] toe white man I now have a flaw
an otherwise flawless thing someone send
the damn about your feet sad we are done
I mean what's the no well I cannot share
this information on the base of my
criminate me and that's all I can say
about that but all right well how breath
averse we just had luenell on here
breaking down the Kraft type of business
side look into the camera please and let
comics know why they should be listening
to this you should be listening to the
hot breath pod cast because number one
the host is very in for matures and
asked good pertinent question because
you could learn some if you shut the
[ __ ] up and watch for a minute which a
ad deed millennial asses and because I'm
on here and we're trying to keep it 100
and he had the foresight to come and
interview me and I'm just trying to keep
it real and help you aunt you don't mean
no harm but if you suck like it out the
way please luenell thanks for being on
hot breath yes man just say and if you
suck get out the way come on go get her
awesome great interview Thank You Lou no
I'm really encouraging [ __ ] out of the
way loser
you're [ __ ] loser
[Laughter]
you gotta do you got a card if I always
get one from Chris or build okay
absolutely so that you will know where
to send the link to and everything might
support this thing I'm pretty sure
nobody really asks no but they don't ask
us the right [ __ ] exactly thanks the cow
pasture comics writing [ __ ] that's why
I'm doing it no no ha
[Music]